>> THE NATION'S BORDER
CZAR HITTING UP ONE OF THE
LIBERAL LATE NIGHT SHOWS
THAT HASN'T BEEN
CANCELLED.
HARRIS GOING AFTER THE
ADMINISTRATION USUAL
ANTAGONISTS, LIKE EVIL RED
STATE GOVERNORS WHO REMIND
HER TO DO HER JOB AND
VISIT THE BORDER.
>> TALK ABOUT POLITICAL
THEATER.
PLAYING GAMES WITH
PEOPLE'S LIVES, WITH THEIR
LIVES.
I JUST THINK IT IS AN
ABSOLUTE DERELICTION OF
DUTY.
IF YOU SEE A PROBLEM AND
IF WE AGREE THAT WE NEED
TO ADDRESS IT, THEN IF
YOU'RE A LEADER,
PARTICIPATE IN A SOLUTION,
RIGHT?
WHEN WE FIRST CAME IN
OFFICE, THE FIRST BILL
THAT WE PROPOSED WAS FOR A
PATHWAY FOR CITIZENSHIP,
WAS TO FIX A BROKEN
IMMIGRATION SYSTEM WHICH
WAS BROKEN UNDER THE
PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION.
>> KAMALA WORKING OVERTIME
TO SPIN HER BORDER
SECURITY NARRATIVE.
IT IS SUCH A BLATANT LIE,
DEMOCRATS ARE FORCED TO
CALL HER OUT.
>> KAMALA HARRIS IS
ABSOLUTELY WRONG ON THAT.
IT IS NOT SECURE.
WE HAVE A LOT OF WORK TO
DO.
I'M NOT HERE TO GET IN A
FIGHT OR TOW THE
DEMOCRATIC LINE, I'M HERE
TO SPEAK THE TRUTH, WE DO
HAVE MORE WORK TO DO.
>> KAMALA'S VISIT TO LATE
NIGHT WOULDN'T BE COMPLETE
WITHOUT SOME KISSING UP TO
HER BOSS.
>> DID YOU EVER ALSO GIVE
ADVICE ON YOUR POSITION?
>> YOU KNOW, I WILL TELL
YOU, FIRST OF ALL, I LOVE
JOE BIDEN, I REALLY DO.
HE IS VERY THOUGHTFUL AND
HE IS VERY KIND.
SO HE IS THOUGHTFUL ABOUT
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE IN
TERMS OF THE WORK WE'VE
DONE AND IT HAS BEEN
HISTORIC WORK.
WHAT I WILL SAY IN TERMS
OF THE INTERPERSONAL
RELATIONSHIP, HE KNOWS THE
JOB AND HE CARES ABOUT
PARTNERSHIP.
>> IT IS SO FUNNY, DANA.
SHE STRIKES ME AS SOMEBODY
YOU STRIKE UP A
CONVERSATION WITH AT AN
AIRPORT BAR, YOU KNOW,
THEY'VE BEEN THERE FOR A
COUPLE OF HOURS.
>> WHEN YOU LEAVE, WHAT
ARE THE WORDS YOU
REMEMBER?
>> NOTHING.
>> YOU'RE LIKE WOW.
I MET THIS PERSON AT THE
BAR, I CAN'T REMEMBER WHAT
WAS SAID.
>> I THINK THERE'S A
THEORY.
SHE WAS ON SETH MEYERS.
THEY PUT HER OUT THERE TO
MAKE SURE AMERICA DOESN'T
SEE HER.
>> THAT'S PROBABLY TRUE,
EXCEPT FOR UNFORTUNATELY
NOW IT IS ALL OVER SOCIAL
MEDIA.
>> WELL WITH THE NUMBER
ONE SHOW.
>> EVERYONE GETS TO SEE
IT.
WE WILL BRING IT TO YOU SO
YOU CAN SEE IT, AMERICA.
THE IMMIGRATION STUFF JUST
BAFFLES ME.
HERE YOU ARE THE FIRST
WOMAN VICE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES, GIVEN
THE TOUGHEST ASSIGNMENT
AND YOU TAKE A PASS.
NOTHING IS GOING TO HAPPEN
ON THE BORDER ON
IMMIGRATION REFORM UNTIL
THE BORDER IS SECURE.
YOU CAN'T EVEN HAVE THE
CONVERSATION.
FOR SOME PECULIAR REASON
THEY REFUSE TO DEAL WITH
IT.
SHE WAS IN AUSTIN LAST
WEEK DOING A FUNDRAISER ON
ABORTION RIGHT.
SHE'S LITERALLY THERE AND
DOESN'T DO ANYTHING.
HER IDEA OF LEADERSHIP IS
TO SAY THE OTHER SIDE
NEEDS TO COME UP WITH A
SOLUTION.
>> WHAT?
THAT'S THE OPPOSITE IN THE
DICTIONARY OF WHAT
LEADERSHIP IS.
LEADERS PROPOSE SLUTHSDZ
OR SHE'S IN A POSITION TO
CONVENE.
THERE'S POWER IN THAT, TO
BE ABLE TO SAY YOU, YOU,
YOU, I WANT YOU AT THE
WHITE HOUSE MONDAY
MORNING, 8:00.
WE HAVE TO COME UP WITH
FOUR SOLUTIONS.
SHE COULD DO THAT, SHE
COULD TRAVEL IF SHE WANTED
TO.
REMEMBER THE ANNOUNCEMENT
SHE MADE THAT ALL THE
COMPANIES WERE GOING TO
SAVE ROOT CAUSES OF THE
PROBLEM, THEY WERE GOING
TO PUT A BUNCH OF
BUSINESSES THERE.
DO YOU THINK ANYBODY IS
DOING THAT?
WHAT REPORTER FOLLOWED UP
TO SEE IF THAT HAPPENED,
NO ONE.
SHE'S GOT POWER.
SHE DOESN'T USE IT.
INSTEAD OF DOING A REAL
INTERVIEW, THEY GO ON A
COMEDY SHOW, WHICH I LOVE.
THERE'S A TIME AND A PLACE
FOR IT.
BUT IF YOU ARE FACING ALL
THESE CRISES, 80% OF
AMERICANS THINK YOU'RE NOT
ON THE RIGHT TRACK, I AM
NOT SURE SETH MEYERS IS
THE PRICE TO GO TO DELIVER
A MICHAEL JACKSON.
>> -- A MESSAGE.
>> THE FIRST, ONLY
NONBINARY HOST OF LATE
NIGHT TV.
JESSE, THE TRUTH, DANA HIT
ON IT, IF SHE WAS ACTUALLY
DOING A GOOD JOB, SHE HAD
BE ON A SHOW PEOPLE WOULD
WATCH.
RIGHT?
THERE'S A TOTAL AUDIENCE
OF 12.
>> I HEARD RUMORS, THEY
MAY PUT HIM ON PEACOCK.
>> DANA IS RIGHT.
WE HAVE NO EVIDENCE THAT
ANY OF THESE COMPANIES
SPENT ANY MONEY IN CENTRAL
AMERICA.
IN FACT, THEY LAUNCHED AN
ANTI-CORRUPTION TASK
FORCE.
THEY HAVEN'T MADE A SINGLE
INDICTMENT SINCE THEY
LAUNCHED IT.
ALSO, THE STATE DEPARTMENT
JUST ISSUED A TRAVEL
WARNING FOR BELIZE BECAUSE
GANGS HAVE TAKEN OVER THE
COUNTRY.
GUATEMALA IS NOW A NARC OH
STATE AND THEY'RE
SUSPENDING CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHTS.
HE WIL
EL SALVADOR, MOST
COUNTRY IN THE WORLD,
FIRST LADY OF HONDURAS
ARRESTED FOR FRAUD.
FOREIGN MINISTER OF CANADA
SAYS WE HAVE A PROBLEM
WITH MIGRANTS SO THEY
FIRED HER.
EVERYTHING IN CENTRAL
AMERICA HAS GOT ESPECIALLY
WORSE.
NOTHING SHE HAS DONE THERE
HAS HELPED.
THE CARTELS ARE MAKING
RECORD PROFITS.
$13 BILLION LAST YEAR.
THEY SHATTERED ALL TIME
BORDER CROSSING RECORDS
TWO YEARS IN A ROW.
THEY LOST TRACK OF 20,000
MIGRANT KIDS.
THEY LOST TRACK AFTER THEY
HANDED THEM TO SPONSORS
THAT ARE BASICALLY
PERVERTS.
FENTANYL OVERDOSES AT AN
ALL-TIME HIGH.
I THINK TWO DOZEN
JURISDICTIONS DECLARED
EMERGENCIES, STATE OF
EMERGENCY BECAUSE OF THE
MIGRANT CRISIS.
SHE SAID THIS IS TRUMP'S
FAULT.
THE WAY TO FIX THE PROBLEM
AT THE BORDER IS AMNESTY.
THAT'S LIKE POKING HOLES
IN A BOAT AND SAYING
YOU'RE FIXING THE BOAT.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK,
JESSICA.
YOU'RE UNTHE UNENVIABLE
POSITION TO HAVE TO DEFEND
KAMALA.
>> I DON'T HAVE TO.
>> OKAY.
GOOD.
SO JUDGE.
>> NO, I HAVE OTHER THINGS
TO SAY.
I HAVE ONE POSITIVE THING.
WHEN YOU SAY THE BORDER
ISN'T SECURE, WHEN
EVERYONE CAN SEE WHAT'S
GOING ON, EVERYONE TUNES
OUT AT THAT POINT, EVEN IF
YOU AGREE WITH THE
DEMOCRATIC POSITION THAT
WE NEED MORE JUDGES DOWN
THERE, MORE FACILITIES TO
MAKE IT SAFER.
IF YOU THINK THIS GAME OF
BUSING PEOPLE BACK AND
FORTH IS DISGUSTING, WHICH
I HAPPEN TO THINK, I DON'T
LIKE THAT ERIC ADAMS SENT
PEOPLE THERE, GREG ABBOTT
AND GOVERNOR DUCEY.
TIM RYAN IS AN
ANTI-ESTABLISHMENT GUY.
NOT A BIG DEAL FOR TIM
RYAN TO SAY THAT, IT HELPS
HIM.
IN THE DEBATE LAST NIGHT
HE WANTED TO SAY I VOTE
FOR THINGS I AGREE WITH
AND STAND FOR OHIO ON
THINGS THAT DON'T HELP OUR
STATE.
PEOPLE GLAZE OVER.
I WATCH THIS DOWNTURN IN
TERMS OF DEMOCRATIC
SUPPORT ON THE ISSUE OF
IMMIGRATION, EVEN A COUPLE
OF WEEKS AGO, WE WERE UP
ONE OR TWO POINT, NOW
WE'RE UNDERWATER.
EVERYTHING THAT'S COME OUT
ON THE HA
ISSUE OF
IMMIGRATION, IT IS
PARALLEL TO WHAT'S GOING
ON WITH CRIME AND
MRISSING.
IT WILL NEVER BE INFLATION
AND THE ECONOMY, BUT IF
YOU ALLOW PEOPLE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DISCOUNT
EVERYTHING THAT YOU SAY
AFTER THE BORDER IS
SECURE, THEY DO NOT KNOW
WHAT YOUR POSITION IS.
THEY CAN'T TELL YOU WHAT
THE POLICIES ARE TO FIX
IT.
NOT SAYING THEY WAKE UP
AND SAY BUILD THE WALL,
THAT'S NOT GOING TO
HAPPEN.
THEY DON'T THINK THEY'RE
SERIOUS.
>> EVEN JESSICA AGREES
KAMALA IS AN UNMITIGATED
DISASTER NOT JUST FOR
AMERICA BUT THE WORLD.
>> I THINK THAT'S WHAT SHE
SAID, TOO.
LOOK, I DON'T KNOW HOW THE
WOMAN GETS OUT OF BED AND
FACES THE WORLD.
SHE'S A CATASTROPHE.
SHE SHOULD HAVE BEEN ON
THE NUMBER ONE COMEDY
SHOW.
WHAT IS THE NAME OF THAT?
LOOK, YOU KNOW, MAYBE WHEN
SHE SAYS THE BORDER IS
SECURE, MAYBE YOU
SHOULDN'T HAVE TO LISTEN
TO ANYTHING AFTER THAT
BECAUSE YOU KNOW THAT'S A
LIE.
SO IT DOESN'T MATTER
WHETHER IT STOPS SOMEONE
FROM HEARING THE OTHER
THING SHE'S SAYING BECAUSE
YOU KNOW RIGHT THEN AND
THERE SHE'S LYING.
THEN SHE SAYS I LOVE JOE
BIDEN.
EXCUSE ME, WASN'T JOE
BIDEN A SEGREGATIONIST
WHEN YOU WERE DEBATING HIM
IN DEBATES FOR PRESIDENCY.
THEN SHE TALKS ABOUT HIM,
SHE SAYS HAVING BEEN VICE
PRESIDENT, HE KNOWS WHAT
THE JOB INVOLVES.
SHE'S BASICALLY SELLING
HERSELF TO YOU SAYING
BECAUSE HE WAS VICE
PRESIDENT, HE CAN BE A
GOOD PRESIDENT.
SO I COULD BE A GOOD
PRESIDENT, TOO, BUT
EVERYBODY KNOWS JOE IS A
DISASTER AND YOU'RE A
DISASTER, TOO.
SO IF SHE USED ANY ENERGY
AT ALL IN TRYING TO DEAL
WITH THE ISSUE, WHETHER IT
IS DEAD PEOPLE, 800 OF
THEM SO FAR, YOUNG PEOPLE,
CHILDREN COMING OVER THE
BORDER, PEOPLE COMING IN
WITH COVID, FENTANYL,
ANYTHING, AMERICANS
SUFFERING AT THE HANDS OF
THOSE ILLEGALS, NOT ALL OF
THEM, BUT THERE'S
CERTAINLY A PERCENTAGE WHO
ARE CRIMINALS.
NOW WE HAVE THE DRUG
ARTERY.
SHE CAN'T ARTICULATE ANY
OF THAT.
SHE DESERVES NOT TO BE,
YOU KNOW, THE FIRST FEMALE
VICE PRESIDENT.
IT IS AN INSULT TO WOMEN
WHO ARE IN POWER.
>> I FORGOT TO SAY MY GOOD
THINGS.
AFTER THE DITTY ABOUT I
LOVE JOE BIDEN, SHE TALKED
ABOUT THINGS THE DEMOCRATS
HAVE DONE, INVESTMENT IN
INFRASTRUCTURE, IN
PROTECTING THE CLIMATE,
LOWERING HEALTH CARE
COSTS.
THOSE ARE THINGS DEMOCRATS
HAVE TO BE RUNNING ON.
SGLM INFRASTRUCTURE?
>> I RUN ON BRIDGES.
>> WHAT HAVE THEY BUILT?
>> INFLATION.
>> EXACTLY.
>> JOE BIDEN GOT 13
REPUBLICAN SENATORS TO
SIGN ONTO THAT BILL.
>> SHOW ME A BRIDGE THEY
BUILT.
>> THEY'RE IN PROCESS.
GO